schön dass sie dabei sind herzlich
willkommen bei halle deutschland und zu
coroner kompakt unter anderem berichten
wir da heute über ein hotel dass einige
seiner leeren zimmern jetzt obdachlosen
anbietet und wir begleiten einen
rettungsteam in kroner zeiten
dazu geht es um ihre fragen heute
beantwortet von unserer rechts expertin
sarah attacke zunächst aber das neueste
von diesem dienstag und einer schülerin
die gerade so gar nicht bei ihren
leisten bleibt statt schuhe gibt es hier
schutz wie sie ihre als ihr freund noel
ihr erzählt dass es auch seine
intensivstation kam noch schutzkleidung
gibt sattelt die schumacher in christine
wehmut sofort um sie beginnt mit der
produktion von schutz visieren die
anleitung dazu findet sie im internet
wir haben sehr viele anrufe sehr viele
leute die sich interessieren
die kommen die probieren und wir haben
auch schon sehr viele abgegeben
aus ist der renner kann man so sagen
aus den folien macht christine
normalerweise probe schuhe die
schaumstoff halterung ist eine
umfunktionierte einlegesohle für
diabetiker reich wird christine mit dem
verkauf der visieren nicht die einnahmen
decken gerade mal die kosten
doch es geht hier um das glücksgefühl
helfen zu können total klasse
diese idee dass wir jetzt was zu tun
haben und dass wir natürlich auch helfen
können in den krankenhäusern und
arztpraxen sind ihre schutz wie sie ihre
ein voller erfolg das läuft super
eingeschlagen wie eine granate und ist
mittlerweile ein selbstläufer
wir hatten als chirurgische praxis nur
den einfachen mundschutz vorrätig der
schützt ein bisschen vor spritzen der
flüssigkeit und schützer etwas die
patienten aber dieses visier es
wirkungsvoll ab 50 stück produzieren
christina und ihre kollegen am tag die
auftragslage ist gut denn schutzkleidung
wird weiterhin dringend benötigt
als erste deutsche großstadt führt jener
die masken pflicht ein
eine weitere maßnahme zum schutz der
bevölkerung wenn ich eine maske bekommen
frage ich sie auch nicht an erster linie
bei münsters rapper schützt und nun war
mutter vor allem die anderen schützt
auch der kommenden woche soll das tragen
von schutzmasken in supermärkten in
gebäuden mit publikumsverkehr und im
öffentlichen nahverkehr zur pflicht
werden wir wissen ja dass der
versorgungsengpass mit masken bundesweit
ist das heißt wir können zwar die
sensiblen bereiche versorgung
gesundheitswesen usw
aber eben nicht alle einwohnerinnen und
deswegen bitten wir um mitarbeit der
schutz vor einer infektion sei zwar
durch das tragen der sogenannten ffp
zwei masken gegeben aber auch ein selbst
gebauter mund nasen schutz hält
natürlich tröpfcheninfektion zurück
tröpfchen zurück wenn man niest und
hustet insofern ist er für den schutz
von anderen sicher von relevanz dass
johns hopkins institut meldet heute 67
1051 infizierte und 15 1824 genesene und
als expertin heute bei uns im studio ist
sarah tacke die leiterin der zdf
redaktion recht und justiz schön dass
sie hier sind hallo gesehen in dem
beitrag masken pflicht in jena soll
kommen ist das auch außerhalb von jener
bundesweit denkbar
ganz klar ja juristisch spricht nichts
dagegen es kann zwar keine
bundeseinheitliche anordnung geben aber
jedes bundesland und auch die kommunen
können es einzeln anordnungen es
vorstellbar dass das ähnlich ist wie bei
dem kontakt verboten kontakt sparen
ausgangs verboten dass sich wieder die
länder zusammen mit der bundeskanzlerin
hinsetzen und sagen gibt es vielleicht
möglichkeiten die strikten ausgangs
verbote zu lockern und eine einheitliche
masken pflicht einzuführen
sie mussten aber wieder von jedem
bundesland angeordnet werden und dann
ist es ähnlich auch die bei den
ausgangssperren und kontakt verboten
dass es auch wieder wenn man dem ganzen
zuwider handelt also ich keine maske
aufsetzt obwohl es diese pflicht dann im
bundesland oder in der stadt in der mond
gibt dann kann es sein dass man dann
auch wieder mit bußgeldern daran
erinnert wird und dafür bestraft wird
wenn man
den licht dementsprechend handelt auch
da haben wir dann wieder die höhe
die bundeseinheitlich gilt nämlich
25.000 euro als maximum sind wir
gespannt da wird noch darüber gesprochen
jena wahrscheinlich der vorreiter für
diese geschichte vielen dank für die
erste einschätzung sei attac und sie
bleiben ja noch bei uns denn später
beantworten wir weitere fragen und zwar
dann ihre fragen die fragen unserer
zuschauer nicht nur pflicht sondern vor
allem aus selbstschutz das sind die
masken in den gesundheitsberufen wie zum
beispiel im rettungsdienst ist ja klar
denn die notfallsanitäter die ärzte
kommen natürlich um den direkten
körperkontakt nicht herum so auch nicole
wucherer und sascha wolf die wir bei
einem einsatz begleiten durften
sanitäter einsatz in zeiten von corona
nicole buchara und sascha wolf sind
südlich von stuttgart unterwegs in
filderstadt ein 39-jähriger mann klagt
über atemnot verdacht auf infektion mit
dem corona virus die notfall sanitäterin
verschafft sich einen überblick und
sonstige vorerkrankungen noch mal
daraufhin 20 eine medikation sie haben
sonst keine tabletten außer die
allergien wie jetzt pollen hausstaub so
das war quasi jeder hat oder hüfte und
jetzt sind sie einfach aber auch mit
titanic haben jetzt mit dazu oder obwohl
der mann bereits letzte woche negativ
auf das kroner virus getestet wurde
zeigt er die einschlägigen symptome wie
werden sie oben checken kontrollieren
und ich denke aufgrund dessen sie würden
sie wahrscheinlich auch mal mit teil
temperatur die haben aber den pfosten
wir haben jetzt atmen isoliert werden
mit blaulicht geht es richtung
krankenhaus
dort angekommen übernimmt
rettungssanitäter sascha wolf die
anmeldung des patienten
ich muss ihnen anmelden verdacht auf
cola oder mit corona und da muss man
einfach anmelden dass er gleich getestet
wird hier und wiegen krone hat man hier
einen speziellen bereich eingerichtet
ein zelt vor dem eigentlichen
krankenhaus wir haben patienten wollen
wir uns mal ein zelt für melden
als verdacht auf eventuelle corona
zusätzlich noch herzinfarkt
sie ist aber trotzdem dass wir hier so
sollen die aufnahme zieht sich hin als
der patient dann auch noch anfängt zu
hyperventilieren macht nicole buchdruck
sascha wolf eilt los und sorgt dafür
dass der mann schnell im krankenhaus
aufgenommen wird
die mediziner sind auf einen solchen
corona verdachtsfall vorbereitet und
tragen spezielle schutzkleidung
die machen hier in abstrichen
vorsichtshalber jetzt in die infektion
bereich reingefahren dass sie das gleich
abklären können trotz negativen markt
strich und es ist für uns auch spannend
also heute einiges los
für nicole wucherer ist es zwei ihr
traumjob aber gerade in zeiten von
corona für der sie an ihre grenzen
auch weil in der branche ja ohnehin
schon personalmangel herrscht wo du
kommst wenn deine grenzen anwalts grad
ne doppelbelastungen geschmack ich sagen
wir wissen gar nicht wo selber hinführt
jeder von uns ist total unsicher wir
wissen nicht ob material nachkommen wir
wissen nicht ob wir weiterhin in schutz
haben wir wissen nicht wie der einbruch
kommen wird ob die leute sich daran
halten werden
das ist alles sehr ungewissen diese
ungewissheit wird die sanitäter erst
einmal weiter begleiten gewissheit aber
immerhin bei ihrem 39-jährigen patienten
das corona virus konnte bei ihm nicht
nachgewiesen werden
je stärker das öffentliche leben
eingeschränkt ist desto größer wird auch
die note obdachlosen menschen in unserem
land denn das verkaufen von
straßenzeitungen betteln oder flaschen
sammeln all das fällt ja mehr oder
weniger komplett aus gerade hinzu kommt
dass die vielen hilfseinrichtungen
geschlossen haben oder im notbetrieb
laufen ein hotel in mainz will das
ändern und vergibt einige der
leerstehenden zimmer jetzt ein
obdachloser klaus perlich auf dem weg in
sein hotelzimmer
der 78 jährige witwer ist herzkrank und
seit einem jahr obdachlos mit der
ausbreitung des corona virus wurde sein
der lage immer schwieriger
bis der verein armut und gesundheit im
vor wenigen tagen einen vorschlag macht
ich habe von dem verein angeboten
bekommen
in dem hotel unterzukommen und was ich
natürlich sehr gerne angenommen habe und
habe nun wenigstens für eine gewisse
zeit die sicherheit dass ich mehr oder
weniger ein zuhause habe klaus perlich
ist einer von 25 obdachlosen die in
diesem mainzer hotel aufgenommen werden
das verändert auch den alltag für die
mitarbeiter jetzt müssen wir das ein
bisschen umgestalten auf komplettservice
wir müssen auch schauen dass und auch
ein sozial pädagogischen dienste mit
einplanen
ein sicherheitsdienst den wir noch mit
einplanen als hotelbetrieb sind
natürlich auch nicht so gewohnt sonst
gehen geschäftsreisende und tagungsgäste
ein und aus das hier nun obdachlose
unterkommen ist in zeiten von ausgangs
beschränkungen besonders hilfreich war
es viele menschen glaube ich in diesen
tagen nicht realisieren ist dass
wohnungslose menschen eine
hochrisikogruppe darstellen und zwar
weil sie häufig multimorbide also
verschiedene erkrankungen chronische
erkrankungen haben und daher besonders
gefährdet
wohnungslose menschen in kernen nicht zu
hause bleiben sie haben kein zuhause
land und stadt übernehmen alle kosten
klaus perlich wünscht sich dennoch dass
ein hotelaufenthalt nicht lange dauert
ich hoffe dass diese solche muss ich um
trainer sagen ein ende
trotz allem obwohl ich ja ein vater im
moment habe er aber noch ganz das hotel
in mainz bietet menschen unterkunft und
schutz die derzeit besonders
schutzbedürftig sind
ja und auch in anderen branchen sorgt
die krise für ganz neue aufgaben und
bringt wundervolle ideen hervor die
gastronomie zum beispiel schwer
getroffen von der bundesweiten
kontaktsperre der gäste dürfen seit
letzter woche ja nicht mehr bewertet
werden was nicht heißt dass überall die
küche kalt bleiben und die bereits
eingekauften vorräte einfach so
vergangenen choral lg kocht jeden tag
dabei ist sein geschäft firmen- und
eventcatering völlig zusammengebrochen
18 von 22 mitarbeitern sind in kurzer
zeit doch der 41-jährige und weitere
hamburger kirche und restaurantbetreiber
wie patrick rüther haben aus der not
eine tugend gemacht sie kochen für die
helden der krise supermarkt mitarbeiter
pflegekräfte ärzte labor angestellte
eine idee des berliner kochs max strom
wir haben uns ihnen angeschlossen und
gesagt wir müssen so was auch dringenden
hamburg starten und hamburg hat sich als
sehr solidarisch und schnell gezeigt 500
essen für helden produzieren er und
seine mitstreiter nun jeden tag dazu
1400 mahlzeiten pro woche für obdachlose
für die die üblichen hilfsangebote in
der krise stark eingeschränkt sind im
moment können wir nichts machen unseren
leben liegen brach und uns hilft das
sagen wir mal auch was ein bisschen sinn
in diesen zeiten angeht
es ist unheimlich motivierend die hälfte
des tages verbringen sie ihren laptop
und handy lieferanten denen ebenfalls
die kundschaft weggebrochen ist spenden
zutaten die müssen verteilt werden
gerade ist tv koch tim mälzer in der
leitung kommt kein ende also die
anfangen werden wir unsere kapazitäten
sind begrenzt totally nie mit steinpilz
füllungen dazu entenbrust oder salat an
diesem tag kochen sie unter anderem für
das hamburger hygiene-institut
ausgeliefert wird die ware von den chefs
höchstpersönlich im transporter der
kitchen guerilla am zielort werden sie
bereits sehnsüchtig erwartet die
mitarbeiter sind für die hygiene im
gesamten hamburger stadtgebiet zuständig
in pandemie zeiten eine mammut aufgabe
sie sind dankbar für die solidarität der
kirche
danach müssen sie neue
lebensmittelspenden abholen im
frischeparadies am hamburger fischmarkt
gibt es frische pasta die sonst
weggeschmissen werden müsste tallinn mit
lammragout schiene mit spinat choral lg
hat direkt ein paar rezepte im kopf die
maultaschen die würde ich ganz
klassischen er berührt zubereiten und es
wird nicht langweilig ein gutes rezept
um durch die krise zu kommen und so sind
auch choral lg und seine mitstreiter
helden helden die für helden kochen
das kann man wirklich so sagen richtig
tolle aktion der sich auch immer mehr
köche und restaurants anschließen wie
bei mir im studio ist jetzt noch mal
sarah attacke die leiterin unserer
zdf-redaktion für recht und justiz und
wir haben viele fragen bekommen sie sich
auf ihren fachbereich spezialisieren und
darum drehen urlaubsreise studiert
werden bieten zum beispiel nicht schlage
vor wir legen direkt los axel brennen
der hat nämlich urlaub gebucht kann dann
aber nicht antreten darf der arbeitgeber
trotzdem darauf bestehen dass ich den
genehmigten urlaub nehmen
ganz klar ja die sache des arbeitgebers
ist es nicht um zu entscheiden ob man wo
man sich erholt und man kann sich ja
theoretisch auch zu hause erholen das
heißt man hat keinen anspruch darauf
jetzt seinen urlaub zurück zu geben
leider für viele die urlaub gebucht
haben jetzt nicht nehmen können aber aus
arbeitgebersicht ist das auch
verständlich weil sonst würde sich alles
ins zweite halbjahr verlagern oder ins
nächste jahr
und auch dass es nicht tragbar deswegen
ist das hier auch wieder eine frage wo
man zusammen kommen muss und man hat als
arbeitnehmer der bereits bestätigten
urlaub hat keinen anspruch den
zurückzugeben
also viele urlaube zu hause sind die eh
viele gerade da jemand anders fragt von
unseren zuschauern und befürchtet dass
dabei die miete nicht mehr vollständig
zahlen kann oder vielleicht gar nicht
sogar was kann derjenige tun oder
diejenige jedes betrifft jetzt natürlich
viele und ab morgen ab dem 1
vieten gibt es einen besseren
mieterschutz in deutschland extra wegen
der korona krise da muss man aber
aufpassen weil da oft falsch das oft
falsch verstanden wird das heißt nicht
dass man seine miete nicht mehr zahlen
muss sondern dass man nicht mehr
gekündigt werden kann wenn man seine
miete jetzt aufgrund der krise aktuell
nicht zahlen kann
ganz wichtig ist es aber mit dem
vermieter ins gespräch zu gehen weil
irgendwann muss man die miete zahlen dh
dass herausschieben führt nicht dazu
dass man sie nicht mehr zahlen muss und
deswegen auch mal schauen vielleicht ist
es beim vermieter ja auch so dass der
gerade job probleme hat kein geld hat
auf die mieteinnahmen angewiesen ist
vielleicht kommt man sich sehr entgegen
dass man weniger zahlt dass man
insgesamt reduzieren kann aber das nur
im dialog weil der mieterschutz ist
nicht so umfassend dass man seine miete
nicht mehr zahlen muss was man aber auch
menschen raten kann die ihre miete
aktuellen nicht zahlen können das
wohngeld beantragen
ok sehr guter tipp dass wir das auch
immer gehört haben menschen die etwas
gekauft haben wie gaby butscher zb
schmidt böttcher wie ist das mit
umtauschrecht wenn jetzt die geschäfte
geschlossen können sie das noch
zurückgeben oder wann und wie ja ganz
schwierig und asche ist erstmal das ist
frage der kulanz die kulanz besteht
grundsätzlich natürlich fort und es geht
das was beim kauf vereinbart wurde
und da ist de facto bei vielen läden die
aktuell geschlossen nicht möglich ist
dinge umzutauschen auf kulanzbasis oder
aber mängel geltend zu machen
manchmal hilft eine e mail an weil sind
ja alle da e mail an das geschäft um
daran zu erinnern um schon mal
klarzumachen sache hat ein mangel ich
werd ich zurückgeben
und dann kann man sie auch zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt umtauschen oder
zurückgeben
also auch hier gilt einmal mehr sprechen
nachfragenden kontakt treten ist er
sowieso im leben eine wichtige
voraussetzung vielleicht lernen dass
dadurch wieder umso mehr jetzt
gezwungenermaßen angebote fragt der eine
fahrgemeinschaft kann nicht weiterhin
mit meinen arbeitskollegen diese
fahrgemeinschaft aufrechterhalten trotz
des kontaktverbot
leider nein also kommt darauf an wie
groß die schlaggemeinschaft ist und auch
wie also in welchem bundesland er wohnt
weil es ist wirklich so dass diese
kontaktverbot und ausgangssperren in
jedem bundesland ein bisschen
unterschiedlich sind
und genau diese feinheiten sind dann die
unseren alltag beeinflussen
aber es kommt durch die ausgangssperre
weil die uns vor allem privaten
anspricht und nicht
beruflichen zu der absurden situation
dass man nicht mehr mit fünf kollegen
gemeinsam zur arbeit fahren kann
aber wenn der arbeitgeber jetzt ein
umzugsunternehmer oder ein
bauunternehmer ist kann er danach die
fünf kollegen bei der arbeit in ein auto
setzen und zur baustelle fahren lassen
weil diese kontaktsperre die uns alle
einschränken aus private abziehen aber
nicht aus beruflicher aber trotzdem
versuchen wir die ihr beruflich hier
auch einzuordnen einzuhalten kurze
antwort für die letzte frage es geht um
kinderbetreuung ist es zulässig dass
eltern wegen der schließung von schulen
und kindergärten fragt nadine koch ihren
kompletten jahresurlaub nehmen
das problem ist bei kita schließungen
schulschließung bin ich als elternteil
verantwortlicher vermeiden dass meine
kinder betreut werden dass der
arbeitgeber raus ob ich das durch
unbezahlten urlaub durch jahresurlaub
durch überstunden in welcher form auch
immer mache ist meine sache aber der
arbeitgeber muss mir nicht home office
ermöglichen oder mir arbeitszeit
bezahlen dafür dass ich meine kinder
betreut das heißt es ist meine private
pflicht für die betreuung meiner kinder
zu sorgen und in welcher form ich das
mache ist dann auch wieder und auch hier
gilt wieder ins gespräch mit den
arbeitgeber gehen
vielen dank so wie wir das gemacht haben
ins gespräch kommen vielen dank sarah
tacke ja unser corona bloggt er ist
nicht nur kompakt sondern auch jederzeit
verfügbar auf youtube und zwar auf dem
kanal der zdf heute jeden tag eine neue
ausgabe
und für morgen haben wir dafür sie einen
finanz und wirtschaftsexperten
eingeladen wenn sie also da eine
drängende frage haben gerne sofort
mailen corona kompakt at zdf.de das ist
die e mail adresse und einige der fragen
beantworten wir dann morgen wieder hier